making his Pro debut today 6' 7 in so is
hijab that's a big man it's a very big
man I think we saw a video of him
yesterday kind of just feeling out the
cage and he was towering above the the
sides of the
cage I'm slightly worried as as
beautiful as his venue is that
chandelier I'm worried if we're going to
see that come down yes well hijab
training out of fight Zone London and SE
in he's also got Rising MMA star sha
Kamali in his
corner and this is his first B there
there's no pressure an Oxford University
graduate Queen Mary's University
graduate a lot of people will know
Muhammad hijab of his time on speaker
Corner in HDE Park where he can debate
with you no matter who you are he's
debated with so many people and he's
just thr them away there is no match but
tonight is all about the talking's going
to stop now he's going to have to talk
with his fists in the
cage yeah and it T man like that I think
bringing in that intelligence I'd like
to see how it translates his fight IQ
but coming from a gym like fight Zone
London being a j guy knowing Mara the
Jimmy's built up they have a breadth of
grappling Talent there and also getting
his black belt Rog sorry P Bel in Roger
Gracie Academy but he's coming in with a
wealth of experience so I think this is
going to be one to really excite the
crowd both live on the stream and here
in
person yeah it is I mean we've got a
full house here to watch this fight and
I can't even imagine how many people are
watching online on the
pay-per-view yeah I think here it's
getting busier and busier every time I
turn around there's more of a crowd here
there's more seats being put down I'm
just worried about
like people the commentary they'll be
able to hear us speak once the crowd
gets
going absolutely and you see uh Muhammad
hijab here taking his time getting okay
really embracing every moment and with a
debut it's obviously something you want
to
[Music]
do this man has no fear verbally or
physically he's he's challenged them all
on the news
there's a lot of people who are excited
to see
this round
minut as a matter of fact there's
actually three five minute rounds
because this is a professional MLA
bout let's see how long this will last
but I'll tell you something though hijab
is going to have to keep his hands up I
know he's a tall guy six seven in tall
but Reese has got bombs in those hands
these are two very large men I think
we're going to see